bon je voulais vous parler d'un projet
on va faire un gros coup avec canal la
chaîne
j'ai vu les plans d'un très beau projet
bonjour bienvenue un double appel
voilà ce temps dans les statuts à voir
les problèmes ça me paraît bien étrange
ils sont tous devenus incontournables
c'est trop bête avec les gens moi on me
dit souvent qu est ce que c'est pour toi
cas là le plus beau pour moi c'est la
joie les confettis les paillettes
toujours la petite touche d'humour nemec
de canal il paye pas pour rien dès le
mois d'avril
retrouvez tous ces moments mythiques sur
la nouvelle chaîne digitale canal plus
torrides
on va bien se marrer divertissement ou
invités et là c'est le début de l'essai
pas d'amener des parcs moselle et et
kaunas et bien des témoins styles toutes
les émissions cultes on aimerait revenir
aux hans kung fu chaos et placé pour
parler comme toutes les stars qui ont
marqué l'histoire de canal plus on est
sur un très très gros poisson bienvenue
à toi jeune
donc j'ai envie de dire c'est du gagnant
gagnant je me retrouve carrément si
c'est son bonheur ça serait bien ça le
bonheur de tous un monsieur picot
vous faites de recherches sur de
nouvelles formes du bouc et c'est
passionnant
[Musique]
avec canal + story replonger dans la
culture canal+ à partir du 14 avril
seulement sur my canal
allez je fais la bise à tout le monde
[Musique]